[Música]
llegó el momento de conocer lo que dicen
los medios de comunicación revista de
prensa con Marta Moya Bienvenida Marta
muy buenos días Hola Andrés muy buenos
días Marta vamos a abrir con una revista
vamos a ver la revista de prensa de hoy
en México porque ayer la justicia se
pronunció sobre una sentencia histórica
al condenar por primera vez la violencia
con ácido o la violencia con ácido como
feminicidio en grado de tentativa en el
caso de Carmen Sánchez que en paralelo
se ha convertido en una activista en la
lucha y la visibilización de esta lacra
comenzamos con lo que dice la jornada
por ejemplo sí Andrés vamos a empezar
con la jornada que hace un repaso de la
intrahistoria de todo este caso Carmen
Sánchez es una mujer del estado de
México que afirma que fue maltratada
durante 10 años que denunció a su
entonces pareja en tres ocasiones y que
las autoridades nunca hicieron caso de
esa situación cuando decidió separarse
en 2014 la respuesta del tipo de su
exmarido Efrén García fue rociarle con
ácido que le dejó lesiones en la cara en
la nariz en los ojos y en el cuello pasó
ocho meses hospitalizada Y desde
entonces se ha sometido a más de 60
operaciones para restaurar todo su
rostro no para restaurar toda su cara el
tipo estuvo jugado durante 7 años y las
autoridades nunca lo buscaron y además
dieron con él y lo detuvieron en 2021
Solo porque él se sacó una licencia para
ejercer como taxista en el estado de
Nuevo León nunca antes las autoridades
habían buscado al perpetrador de este
bueno de este ataque no contra su
expareja ahora una jueza del Tribunal
Superior de Justicia del Estado de
México ha condenado a la agresora 46
años y ocho meses de cárcel por un
delito de tentativa de feminicidio por
arrojar el ácido contra su expareja es
una sentencia histórica porque nunca
antes México Había juzgado este tipo de
especímenes como tentativa de
feminicidio y es importante también que
se haya aplicado la perspectiva de
género han pasado nueve años Eso sí
desde que pues todo esto ocurrió y
además la víctima se ha convertido en
una activista por los derechos de las
mujeres que sufren este tipo de
violencias y dijo en una entrevista que
si no lo hubiera hecho jamás hubiera
obtenido esta sentencia Marta que dice
por ejemplo medios como el diario El
País el diario El País sostiene Andrés
que este es un caso pionero ya no solo
en México sino en toda la región porque
nunca tampoco en América Latina se había
juzgado un caso de estas características
de violencia ácida como tentativa de
feminicidio además sostiene que gracias
a esta lucha de Carmen Sánchez estados
como Ciudad de México o Puebla han
incluido la violencia ácida en sus
códigos penales para aumentar las penas
contra los agresores sin embargo
sostiene este artículo del país que el
94% de los casos de violencia ácida en
México siguen impunes Marta Qué dice
vamos a revisar lo que dice el animal
político el animal político este medio
mexicano retrata algunas de las
declaraciones que hizo ayer Carmen
Sánchez a la salida de los juzgados
después de obtener esta sentencia
histórica hemos destacado dos citas la
primera es inicié este camino sin la
mano de las instituciones jamás creí que
llegaría este momento diez años
caminando sola diez años de lucha estoy
cansada pero contenta y En referencia a
que no solo la reparación económica es
el fin porque El condenado tendrá que
pagarle más o menos
220 mil dólares por todo el daño causado
Dice Carmen Sánchez que para mí no solo
estar viva es suficiente la violencia
machista y el ácido me arrebataron mi
identidad y mi libertad humana eso decía
ayer bien Marta vamos a cerrar este tema
con lo que registra por ejemplo el
portal sopitas el portal sopita sostiene
Andrés que durante estos nueve años
además de someterse a más de 60
intervenciones reconstructivas para
reconstruir su rostro Carmen Sánchez ha
tenido que enfrentar tratamientos
dermatológicos y aparte discriminación
laboral violencia institucional y otro
tipo de afectaciones tanto físicas como
psicológicas cuando Carmen Sánchez se
presentó en el juzgado lo hizo con un
informe hecho por una abogada forense y
psicológica que decía que además la
víctima era doblemente revictimizada
porque las operaciones estéticas no
están incluidas como los servicios
básicos de salud y que tenía que
costearlas aparte de lo que incluye un
servicio básico de salud y que además
todo esto se agravaba por las
condiciones socioeconómicas de la
víctima Así es Marta un caso lamentable
y que afecta como lo decía usted
anteriormente a muchos países de América
Latina y que de eso también hay una
afectación psicológica en todas estas
mujeres que sufren esto tipo de ataques
Marta vamos a cambiar de tema y ahora
porque la separación entre la obra y el
artista parece que se diluye cada vez
más y un famoso pintor español está
viendo las consecuencias en sus ventas
esto lo reporta el medio del país que
dice sí Andrés nos referimos a Pablo
Picasso el escrito el escritor no el
artista pintor español un artículo del
país titula Picasso cotiza la baja en
tiempos de feminismo sostiene este
artículo del país que coincidiendo con
el 50 aniversario de la muerte del
pintor malagueño un portal de venta de
arte ha observado un decrecimiento
notable en las ventas de las obras de
este artista este artículo sostiene
textualmente al pintor se le ha
derrumbado encima todo el siglo XXI y
sus reivindicaciones feministas lejos
del Lienzo Picasso era difícil oscuro
manipulador carismático narcisista y
narcisista tiránico perdón con las
mujeres nunca antes ni gran depresión de
1929 ni en la crisis financiera de 2008
ni siquiera con la pandemia Picasso
había visto afectaciones en las ventas
de sus obras sin embargo en lo ocurrido
de lo que va de 2023 sus obras se venden
por 88 millones de euros cuando por
ejemplo en 2021 llegaron a alcanzar más
de 600 millones de euros en 2022 más de
465 cita a un comisario de arte el país
que dice la vida y el comportamiento de
un creador no deberían impedirla
apreciación crítica de su obra en
términos estrictamente artísticos pero
las exigencias éticas son hoy mucho más
estrictas que nunca Marta íbamos a
cerrar hoy en Rusia porque el medio
independiente
Moscú Times nos relata que Moscú una
pastelera que confecciona tartas con
decoraciones antibélicas o a favor del
respeto a Ucrania podría no tener un
final tan dulce sí Andrés nos referimos
a la pastelera Anastasia chernicheva una
pastelera
que crea tartas con la bandera de
Ucrania o con motivos y decoraciones con
lemas como a la la guerra
Libertad para Rusia y Ucrania o Putin
morirá pero nosotros nos quedaremos bajo
las leyes estrictas leyes de censura
rusas desde el principio de la ofensiva
esta mujer ha sido detenida a finales de
abril y luego puesta en libertad pero ya
ha tenido que hacer frente a una multa
de aproximadamente 500 dólares además su
panadería se hizo viral en redes
sociales y un canal de extrema derecha
ruso de televisión le hizo una nota
diciendo que su negocio promovía el odio
a Rusia y además servía para recaudar
dinero para el ejército de Ucrania todo
esto pues evidentemente sin pruebas
además sostiene este artículo del mosqui
Times que si vuelve a ser condenada Va a
ir a la cárcel nada más y nada menos que
durante siete años sin embargo
charnisheva está pastelera moscovita
quiere desafiar la ley y cita
textualmente este artículo del Moscú
Times Que ella misma dijo Hasta que me
encarcelen Solo estoy planeando hornear
pasteles Marta una de las tantas
iniciativas que se llevan a cabo allí en
territorio Ruso y que es muy polémico en
contra de la Marta Muchas gracias Nos
vemos entonces la otra semana con más
revista de prensa gracias